joining me right now to discuss the open
border and Reckless spending and debt is
House Majority Leader Louisiana
Congressman Steve scalise Congressman
it's great to see you Mr Majority Leader
thank you so much for being here
always great being with you and good
morning to you Maria I spoke with
Senator Joe manchin
on the ground in Davos this
you cannot have the nation that we have
the workforce that's needed and the
intelligence is going to be needed with
it and development of the skills unless
you have a secured border there's not
going to be any serious talks about
immigration reform until everybody
agrees we will have a secured border
foreign
will we have a secured border under the
Republicans leadership
you're going to see Republicans bring
Bill through the house to actually
secure America's border I hope we get
Senator mansion and other Democrat
Senators who have blocked any attempt to
secure the Border because we're going to
be sending a package of bills to secure
the border to get control of this
problem I mean you talked about the
people on the terrorist watch list those
are just the ones we caught how many
have come across that we don't even know
about right and we're seeing by the way
not just south uh countries from the
southern border we're seeing countries
from all around the world over 150
countries coming across our Southern
border because Joe Biden opened it up he
could close it on his own he won't we're
going to bring legislation to show the
country how to fix this problem let's
get the Senate engaged so they can pass
that bill to the president just
extraordinary what about this upcoming
Showdown on debt uh I know that Joe
manchin has reached out to Kevin
McCarthy to set up a meeting the speaker
also told me that he has directed his
office to set up that meeting so they
will be meeting in terms of identity
find places to cut how will you get our
debt under control
well Joe Biden is the one who needs to
take ownership and responsibility for
this and he's refusing to meet with
Kevin McCarthy up to this point I don't
think that's sustainable Maria because
if you look for the last two years Joe
Biden has gone on a spending spree the
likes our country has never seen before
drunken sailor is what has not to be
associated with the level of spending
you've seen out of Washington and so
what happened is the credit cards are
maxed out that's basically how you hit
the debt ceiling it's the ability to
print more money and that expires when
you hit the debt ceiling and so the only
way to address it is to control spending
or to increase the debt ceiling or a
combination of the two but you can't
just keep increasing the debt limit and
let President Biden keep spending like
he's done that's just not uh it's not
attainable for the future Generations
our country can't handle that so we've
got to get control over spending as
we're having this conversation and Joe
Biden's got to recognize this right now
he's living in denial he's used to you
know speaker Pelosi just give him
another trillion dollars every other
week that's not going to work work we're
not going to do that so we've got to get
control over spending and by the way
that's what is the lead driver of
inflation that's crushing hard work and
families so we've got to stand up for
those families who are struggling Across
America because of the mountains of debt
and the spending that Joe Biden has
exercised these last two years real
quick on the climate agenda I saw your
Tweet about CEOs who are pushing this
new Global stand
yeah you know you think about this
they've been wrecking economies all over
the world I mean they fly to Davos and
what's the carbon footprint by the way
of all these Global elitist liberals
flying in their private jets to Davos to
tell you to change your lifestyle you
know and then they want to go after
Industries they want to kill the oil and
gas industry by the way did they have
solar panels on the wings of their
airplanes when they flew to Davos no
they use jet fuel yet they want to kill
these industries and all they're doing
is empowering foreign countries they're
making our country more reliant on
foreign countries uh whether it's OPEC
nations Russia Iran uh why would we be
doing that when if you want to save the
planet make more things in America we do
it better than anybody else in the world
they need to start recognizing that drop
all this woke agenda that's killing
Americans and it's raising it by the way
it's raising prices on those lowest
income Americans who who can least
afford it so you know this this idea of
this woke America I think people are
rejecting it people are fed up with it
and they see that it's raising their
costs on everything from electricity
City in their house not only gas at the
pump but everything they buy and all
just to push jobs to China who's
building a new coal plant every single
week this is lunacy it's got to end and
we're going to be putting scrutiny on it
all right Congressman it's good to see
you we'll be following your agenda a
house majority leader Steve scalise
thank you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else